i've spent a week at the u.s mexican
border
it's unbelievable what i'm going to show
you here this is part one of a six part
[Music]
series
it's mexico
there's a path right there huh
[Music]
okay what's the name of this bar oh it's
cabrera's
security and investigations okay uh this
is a reporter from out of town i'm just
showing around
okay yeah freelance yeah no no network
okay thank you thank you
all right so raul you know the border
well
well i think i do talk to us you're just
telling me this okay obviously it was
built to here and then there's a bunch
of gaps as you see right here's a bunch
of gaps throughout the wall
uh if you look this way this is still
part of the united states over here
okay you'll see actually you see border
patrol up there on the that other levee
on the other side of that other level
would be the river okay we can't walk
through here though right
right now that's fine okay okay what
they do what they do is
back this way is the international
bridge okay under the international
bridge
that's why they're housing the migrants
and stuff when they get them and they
process them whatever they're doing so
you'll see buses and
traffic flow through here go up this way
to that levy over there
uh-huh they'll take a ride on the levee
and they'll make their way to the
international bridge so
you'll see a lot of traffic like that
the agent is telling us you'll see
traffic where
you'll have buses come through here a
white van and stuff they transport
the people from here to the holding
facility okay and then whatever else
they're going to do
wow so how is it the last couple weeks
is it
is it is it level is it going up is it
going down or hard to
uh as far as it goes they're coming over
here in the hundreds or thousands
they're non-stop
that's a bad part forget about your
border wall i said wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
thousands non-stop every day or yes
every day
at any given time you'll have more than
a thousand people held into that bridge
for processing uh in la jolla last week
for example
they had a thousand within their first
first four hours
from eight to noon or something uh-huh
they had over a thousand people that
they detained
imagine how many got through that's just
what they detained in that at that time
so there's always been like we're going
to go into more of this story in the
next couple days
but there's always been a flow coming
over 2019 there was a big
big uptick right yes and so now there is
two
similar well basically what they did in
this case they said hey it's
you got a hundred days no deportation
for oh for otms otns me
other than mexican if you're from mexico
and you come across a catchy they throw
you right back
all of everyone yes if you're from
honduras and all those other
all those other areas what they do is
they they'll get you they'll process you
and then they'll release you into the
country with walking papers
with the court date promising to come
back to court
so how many come back to court or hard
to say i'm gonna say hard to say but i'm
gonna say next to none
okay you already allowed them you
already allowed them into these
countries
basically that's what they wanted that's
what they're paying to come into they
already paid to come into the country
they already got released with
documentation saying that go anywhere in
the united states and
so i i doubt if they even come back how
much does it cost how much are they
paying say from honduras or guatemala
okay for that i cannot sit on that
amount but just across from reynosa
which is right there in mexico
to the united states they're charging
3500 just across the river that's it
and who is that who is they exactly
let's move let's move this way because
the sun
the cartels that's what they're charging
they're charging just just to hop the
river from reynosa to the united states
is three thousand five hundred dollars
now like i said i know this number for
sure from jalisco mexico to houston
they're charging fifteen thousand
dollars just to go from jalisco mexico
to houston
we talked an immigrant from honduras the
other day they were going from
honduras to uh south carolina to south
carolina uh-huh they were paying 15
000 also to go from there to there
okay there's so much to this story huh
there's a lot to it there's a lot but
i mean a lot of the people coming over
don't have anything they got the shirt
on their pack and that's about it but i
would
still have to pay even like even if
you're just going from
hopping the river from one into another
it's three thousand five hundred how do
they come up with that money
relatives in the states or wherever
senator well western union see that well
that's the other thing they say okay you
know what
um most of the time when they are
released they're released to an address
here in the united states whether it's
houston dallas new york wherever
there's much more as far as people being
exploited sold
here in the united states all right so
here we go
that's mexico over there oh this is the
united states store this is all the us
all that the border wall is not built on
the river it's built back away from the
river
the border wall is not actually meant to
for all
it's not climbable you know what they'll
put a ladder against that thing they'll
hop the fence and get over it
yeah the border wall is just another
tool to help out border patrol
whether it's the drones the helicopters
the horse back the wall
their vehicles it's just another tool to
help them out because imagine if you've
got all this fenced off
yeah by the time someone puts a ladder
here and says fans because remember the
river is that way
yeah why can't they walk this to this
way with a ladder put a ladder against
that fence and hop this fence
water patch already got here to get them
but in this case if we got the catch and
release program going on
the border wall actually does no good
anyways because they want to be caught
a lot of people are crossing the river
saying hey here i am yeah
get me into custody so they could get on
their way
okay but so anyone can get up not anyone
but people that know what they're doing
can get over this yes
not a not a hard thing nope so it just
slows them up a little bit that's what
it's for it's just meant to slow down
the people that way border patrol
instead of having 20 uh agents in this
area now they only have three in this
area
because then they'll fluctuate throw
them out to the broken areas
and they'll funnel people that way and
you already have an agent waiting in
that area
could you do without it though without
the wall without the wall
like if people get over it or it really
does help well like i said it's just
another tool to help them out
because it slows them down and it gives
them enough time to come over here
gotcha gotcha
around 5 30 in the morning next to the
hidalgo bridge they hit a little port of
entry
like i said you all have people that go
in the pool ladders are going to set
wall they'll hop that that
wall quickly but the wall where there's
not like this wall here this one's set
back
off the river okay that other one's
maybe 20 feet from the river so as soon
as you get out of the river
20 feet later boom we throw that ladder
and they'll hop that right in front of
the international bridge where you got
customs and everybody
so they're they're doing what they're
doing
but this is the other thing what people
don't understand
you gotta for example like la jolla
saturday you have a thousand people that
are being detained
over here imagine that resources the
border patrol
is allocating to that one area okay
what about over here because they're all
tied up here with all these families and
all these thousand
kids and people and everything that
means the drugs are passing this way
the other people that are not that don't
want to get caught are passing this way
because everybody's tied up over here
that's
their way of thinking also that's reason
why they say you know what and i'll just
give you an example the other day
the other day out on the river we
actually had a we actually had a boat
show up uh
show up beside us yeah we had seen it on
the water we thought you know the mexico
maybe it's something you had cnn on the
water is that what you said i'm not sure
oh you had seen it on the water okay
we had already seen it on the water yeah
but we had a like the ball pulled up
beside us we thought you know
nothing nothing about it yeah there was
about seven men with machine guns they
pulled up beside us
we didn't see them until they pulled up
beside us on the um
so how does that work legally mexican
both countries can be on the river right
yes but
half of the river belongs to mexico half
belongs to the united states so we're
both there
and you know this is what they told us
we want you all to call border patrol
we're going to cross a bunch of people
right now
and they don't want to walk so either
way they got paid
and they already know they're going to
release them so they wanted us called
water patrol
but we could meet the people on this
side of the river and just pick them up
so the guy the seven guys with seven
guns was that dangerous out there what
everybody in my boat was shooting bricks
and we're going on the boat tomorrow
yes well i don't tell those kind of
stories the other day that
they threw some rocks at us and stuff
like that oh jesus and uh
i guess with the slingshot or something
because you would hear what it would
bounce off the boat
that's why that's what i'll tell someone
that's afterwards you tell the cat
the the the cameraman journalist well
later on later on
we'll tell you before well
all right guys the risks i take to show
the story
roll you're doing it every day though
i've been doing it for the last two
weeks
oh okay it's not an everyday thing so
it's just by the last two weeks we have
been hitting it every day
why do you do it people need to know the
truth what's going on
we do have a problem and it's going to
get worse until hundred days is over aft
see don't get me wrong i understand what
biden is trying to do he wants to
overturn
trump's policies great yeah if that's
what you want to do he's a president he
can
but have a game plan at least have a
strategy what are we gonna do if we're
gonna do this
what are we gonna do so we don't have
the problem that we're having right now
okay okay
[Music]
roll where are we we're in donna texas
at the
one of the processing facilities can we
get closer
let's go
ralston seems to know everybody
and the situation quite well
and he's saying we can walk up so
let's see
so you can just walk up to this
technically yeah
like legally
[Music]
so this to survive the is
see the light pole then i pull this way
straight please i don't have to call the
cops
please just stay across the street
that's the last i'm not going to get
your feet
in your driveway and i pull this way
belongs to
us not to you okay streaks i don't want
you to get hit by traffic that's all i'm
saying man
there ain't no time lieutenant i work
the same field you do the kind of job
transfer i know what what i can and can
do okay this one
i'm done hold on
[Music]
for your safety
okay so it's a bit tense i guess the law
says you can walk up to the line here
and so what it what is this exactly
donna facility there's a donna facility
it's a processing center where basically
they bring the immigrants here this
thing called 260 immigrants
out of 260 there's also 260.
right now they've got close to 5 000
people in this facility
but but 260 originally now now there's a
ton of tents right well right now
everything's under construction right
now they are making the space bigger
two house more people okay okay because
it's massive
yes guys i can't get in there obviously
but
you can see so these are all the
migrants that come over this is their
this is their first stop
uh i'm not sure the process i think from
here yes
well they get processed there's
makeshift facilities where they get
processed under the bridge or
in some other area from there they get
transported over here
gotcha all right well
what's the best we can do thank you
a little tense obviously
but you can see this is this is where a
lot of the migrants are staying
what a big nice facility
at least on the outside who knows what
it's like on the inside
okay so it goes bad quite a ways huh
okay put the camera down no it's fine
you can record anything within view
public access
and now once you're inside that fence
scenario and they say hey you can't have
cameras
well that's different because it's
inside the
trouble buses and stuff okay
okay once you're inside that fence in
there they tell you no cameras you can't
have cameras that that's completely
different because you're inside their
property
once you're in the public ass access
like this road or
the sidewalk or whatever and they tell
you hey you got to do this you got to do
that
you don't have to
because you're in or they oh you can't
record inside our facility
you know what you're not inside your
their facility you're outside of public
access
so as long as you can zoom in that
camera when you can catch the numbers on
that wall
you ain't breaking any laws okay
so how many of these facilities are
there
actual big facilities like this i think
here in the valley you got one in
raymondville one here
and then i said you got the mixture
facility over here next to the
hilarious port of entry and then you
have one under the
lancer doors bridge okay they're
actually under the bridge they'll have a
fencing area and
you'll see people i'll send you some
pictures just so people see people
lying down on the floors and stuff on
the ground
because that's where they're until
they're being processed and stuff to be
shipped over here
okay gotcha done a facility like
say three four months ago like
four months ago was it still up there
was was there still a big
facility there no actually it just moved
here maybe about three months ago it was
farther towards the river
okay so this this one is actually a new
facility
how's that mom and kid getting across
there's no raft down there
so there's just a lot of money being
made here
this guy here definitely sounds like
hotel more important thing we're wearing
bulletproof vests
no i'm not weird i am it's mexico
is it let's go that way we don't know
where the hell they're at but they know
exactly where we're at
so they see gringo with a gopro these
people
paying up a hundred grand 80 000 to come
into the united states
they're away they're all way back yeah
the kids took off no i got a one and a
half that's sad
in the morning they're they're the ones
that get uh
[Music]
scrutinized
you